[Music]
okay so where we start how's the
physical intimacy Billy
my name is Wes and I misrepresent the
wandering nomads
of Mongolia what is the clothes
toilet paper all over our house you see
a problem I see kid with a vivid
imagination he didn't say he was
pretending to be a Mongolian he said he
is one oh my god are those my uggs go
change now I was late when is the last
time that anybody in this family really
felt alive
where's is waking up I'm not doing this
honey dad did mom text you to off to
Mongolia
what brings you to Mongolia my son has
decided that he's the native hey my name
is Iceman
I'm good filmmaker from India my friends
are trying to get to your Glock jeweler
that is I do
macho fuss buddy but you're not even
Mongolian in that case you're gonna want
to talk to my friend but gonna take you
a little bit longer to get there
depending how much you like to push I
[Music]
had to say go to Mongolian
I don't blame you I was in line for 25
minutes we can look your weird nun
[Music]
if you ever realize you're not where you
belong don't be afraid leave all behind
in college
thank you how do you know how to do this
YouTube
[Music]
you